in the lobby of financial piece Plaza
Matthew and Heidi are with us hey guys
how are you hey
welcome welcome good to have you now
where do you two live Los Angeles Los
Angeles a long trip to do a debt-free
scream that's right well it's good to
have you in financial peace Plaza right
here in Martha's place and brought your
own fan club yeah we brought them all
out here they're off we're all we're a
big Dave Ramsey family on both sides so
what cities are they all from we have
Dallas Chicago and st. Louis Wow all
over the place yeah very cool well good
excuse to meet up here in Nashville and
just get to see each other - absolutely
where is it family friends are what all
family very good so mom and dad are here
yep good good awesome so how much debt
have you paid off Dave we paid off three
hundred and thirty two thousand dollars
that's just ridiculous three hundred and
thirty two thousand dollars right that's
a lot yes it felt like a lot crap did
you buy well about 90% of that was all
student loans Oh
so who's the doctor I'm an attorney
attorney okay grad school yeah lawyer
and grad school so what's your grad
degree in commercial real estate oh good
good freelance they had a grad degree in
there a master's degree huh well I've
got it my degree is real estate a
specialization in finance so various I
was just say a finance degree cuz nobody
gets it but you'd appreciate the real
estate love it very Co is that what you
do yep good good for you in LA that's no
sweet no bad deal yeah three hundred and
thirty two thousand and two hundred and
something was student loans huh what was
the other thirty-two some credit cards
we paid for our wedding and kind of so
how long did this take you
uh two years and 11 months my goodness
yeah so you must be making some money
yep what's your household income we
started at about 205 mhm and went out
from there
yeah killer yeah you're doing great how
old are you - 32 and
when almost 30 to go dude
man you guys are killing it 30 years old
making a couple 100 grand a year and you
cleaned up the debt and you did it
posthaste I mean what happened two years
and 11 months ago that made you decide
to get in attack mode
well actually shortly after we we got
married we went through FPU your own
church and Heidi's sister gave us Total
Money Makeover and Dave I gotta admit
some humility on my side we know after
about six months after we went through
it I was like you know I got a finance
degree I could tweak this deal a little
bit oh we always oh we always think this
and part of getting a finance degree is
you have to take one quarter in
arrogance but we actually were involved
in a pretty serious car accident
ooh and weary measured life and said you
know this incomes not guaranteed so we
got gizelle in tents about 24 months ago
and just pedal to the metal the whole
way so yeah yeah way to go so that
little bit of life flashes before your
eyes at a young age and you stop and go
hey we're gonna get serious yeah exactly
so and and you know the last the last
part was incredible we paid off probably
a rate twice or three times as fast as
we did before we before my tweaking so
thanks for it's a perfect plan to let
everyone out of the box don't fix it
it's not exactly yeah well yeah you got
a try understand yeah that's fun but you
still did it though two years 11 months
three hundred and thirty two thousand
dollars paid off at thirty-one
thirty-two years old that's very very
thanks thanks a lot thanks yeah well you
can stand up there then smack them if
they want to take it now yeah that's
perfect yeah you want to tweak this come
here ah yeah that's funny good job guys
Thanks job you got I mean you with your
finance degree you you had to stick some
of this in the in the calculator and go
we have this income we have no payments
yeah we are gonna be able to live give
like no one else we're so excited about
it yeah it's almost you don't know what
to do once we got out of debt we're like
well we don't we have to save for
emergency fund now but it's like just
such a different feeling all that
anxieties completely gone and it's
called financial peace for a reason
yeah I mean you know people are saying
well they make $200,000 here yeah they
do but they paid off three hundred
thirty two thousand over two years
eleven months so this is still ratios
people it's still math it still beans
and rice what was the hardest thing you
do did to get out of debt you know I I
was talking about this
it didn't feel hard when we were doing
it we found a lot of ways to do things
for free and have fun together just
staying in watching movies but once we
finished it I realized how intense we
were I think it's almost like a runner's
high we're homeowners just like you yeah
you get a high from paying off these
loans and it just keeps you going so
there was nothing that seemed too hard
about it we just we just kept going but
the key was definitely the written
budget that was a game changer as soon
as we got really diligent on that
perfected that communication it improved
our marriage and it's just we got so
intense it was great what caught you
off-guard in the process kind of soft
guard I think just actually you know at
one point I would get what I would get a
little discouraged at at one point
thinking man this is taking a long time
and then Heidi would would pull me back
up and vice versa
yeah and it always happened a different
time so there's always one of us that
was able to kind of pull back and I
think that's surprised us about you know
we're young in our marriage and it
surprised us about how we thought we
were close and we thought we
communicated well about money but after
going through this that caught me off
guard you so much closer we are just a
byproduct of doing this together and
just how how incredible it's been for
our relationship and for our
relationships with our family so it's
it's been a lot of fun yeah well you've
gone through this huge positive
experience you went through the you know
the car wreck I mean those two things
together that's like a that's like nitch
your marriage together like a crazy man
awesome yeah that is so awesome people
make fun of you Matt our friends are we
had great friends coworkers were kind of
looking at us especially since a lot of
our student loans were at a low interest
rate people kind of said that's silly
why would you ever pay those off early
and just you know invest your money and
so it was co-workers who kind of who are
not supportive but we had very very very
supportive friends throughout this
process yeah but you do get to kind of
turn the tow Toby Keith song up now how
you like me now
talk to me about your interest rate
$332,000 worth in your face yeah
definitely I can't resist yeah a little
student loan no more debt freed Snoopy
dance right there yeah that could happen
well and you guys have you realized I
mean I'm so far the other side of this
now I was sharing it's been 20 years
that we now look back and realize that
that set the table for us to be able to
literally do once we learned we could do
things like that together we were
literally figured out we can do anything
yeah that's not the income you've got
and the fact you know how to work
together and you have brains and all of
that
I mean you there's no telling where
y'all are gonna be I mean tens of
millions of dollars given away yeah
through you to help other people and in
the scope of your lifetime it's gonna be
amazing when you look back we're looking
forward to it yeah you guys are you're
very cool it's so good to talk to you
you're so inspiring all right let's do
the debt free scream Matthew and Heidi
from Los Angeles three hundred and
thirty two thousand dollars paid off two
years in eleven months making 205 on the
way up only 31 32 years old count it
down let's hear a debt free scream house
the Larson's earned this three two one
that is serious fun absolutely well done
you two
good job very well done